johannesbourg 1800 mètres d'altitude un
ancien camp de lui leur devenue la plus
grande ville et le plus grand centre
commercial industriel et financier
d'afrique du sud plus d'un million
d'habitants une ville en or la ville de
leur espèce de métal jaune malléable
incorruptibles agents de toutes les
corruptions
en 1826 un prospecteur jusqu alors
malchanceux tombé par hasard sur un
affleurement de filons aurifères le plus
riche du monde
des milliers de colons vinrent planté
leur tente sur les bords de ce pactole
solidifie apple quand la bourgade puis
la cité par pti selon l'esthétique du
lingot
l'afrique du sud s'est un peu tout le
monde
les portugais grand des couvents de
terre des espagnols des hollandais des
français huguenots des anglais anglicans
et même quelques temps des allemands de
bismarck en quête d' espace vital
tous ces gens courageux opiniâtre se
sont fait longtemps la guerre d'où le
nom d'union sud-africaine donné au pays
et figurez-vous aussi qu'il y a des
noirs en afrique des banques a eu le
travail en profondeur
vous voyez ce que l'on veut dire le
travail dans les mines la semaine on ne
les voit pas en marche dessus
le dimanche
il se rappelle tendance en le bon vieux
temps de l'ère préindustrielle
leblanc lui verrait plutôt la surface
des choses l'herbe et l'eau l'eau et
l'herbe il aime beaucoup le clapotis des
piscines la terre battue des tennis et
la nature bien ordonnée des terrains de
golf avec leurs petits trouve beaucoup
moins profond que ce que font les
banques
mais un rien d'histoire voici le
monument dévore trekkeurs excusez moi je
ne sais pas très bien comment sautereau
non seulement aux landais
c'est énergique les seuls au monde qui
au lieu de descendre vers le sud sont
remontés vers le nord cherche en quoi la
liberté
ouais
pretoria
est la capitale administrative
le palais de l'union domine la ville
mais n'ont peut-être pas toujours c'est
tous ces problèmes une ville qui se
souvient et qui honore la mémoire
du combattant du transvaal paul crugey
l'illustrent adversaires des angles
vaincu mort en suisse statufié
prétoriens
non loin de sa tombe se trouve celle du
prince christian petit fils de la reine
victoria ainsi les cimetières parfois
concilier les inconciliables
pretoria est aussi le quartier général
de la recherche scientifique et la ville
possède la plus vaste universités
d'afrique du sud dix mille étudiants
jusqu ici point de contestataires
là
au delà des villes
quelque chose d'immense et d'un prêt si
la nature
la nature faune cdo bantous et à
d'autres représentants de la tradition
est rare que l'on soit invité à assister
à la danse des pictons mais le festival
de cham est ouvert à tous ceux qui se
rendent dans le zoulouland il a lieu au
mois de juillet 20 km le d'urnes c'est
une fête religieuse chrétienne qui se
termine par une danse où certains
croient discerner quelques traces de pas
venus à moins qu'il ne s'agisse d'une
nouvelle forme de progressisme
liturgique
le transkei l'un des plus grands
territoires banques il est plus vaste
que la belgique et la hollande réunit 1
million d'habitants ont vite ici près de
la nature d'ailleurs comment faire
autrement
c'est le pays du peuple aux couvertures
rouges dont les femmes fument seraient
demandées petit peu allons tenir les
antilles que superstition on peine à
disparaître ou à faire remplacer
le sorcier guérisseur a conservé son
prestige son grand chapeau à plume et
ses vieilles recettes dans get de pau
drôle qu'un lézard desséché poudre
mystérieuse airbus ouvertes du secret
la chaîne du drakensberg est dit-on
l'épiné dorsale du pays une épine
dorsale qui n'en finit plus 1000
kilomètres de laon ces montagnes s'élève
à plus de 3000 mètres d'altitude et
changent constamment de couleurs des
tons magique de l'eau pour pro noir de
la nuit
et la vallée où l'on pêche mais non lieu
étrange dit de la porte d'or
portes grandes ouvertes et enfoncé
chaque année par un nombre considérable
de touristes
deux touristes à pied à cheval en
voiture acquis sauf
naïve est génial les peintures rupestres
de l'école sud-africaine un peu moins
active depuis
pour pour
oui
oh
l'état libre d'orange l'import capital
blom fontaine autrement dit la fontaine
aux fleurs
c'est le siège de la cour suprême un
haut lieu de la culture en afrique du
sud
son bâtiment le plus ancien le vieux
rade salles aujourd'hui monument
rationnelle commémore l'oeuvre des
pionniers
non loin de lui le bisc
que voici a été élevé en mémoire des
femmes et des enfants qui m'ont sûrs
pendant la guerre anglo bon bout plus
exactement
comme dans toutes les villes d'afrique
du sud à bloemfontein tout ce qui n'est
pas béton et fleurs et jardins
mais ce pays prospère aventureuse et
ultramoderne a eu l'intelligence de
garder ouvert le grand livre des beautés
d'autrefois
le parc national kruger est l'une des
plus ancienne réserve d'animaux sauvages
du continent afrique on ne compte plus
ici en hectares mais en milliers de
kilomètres carrés
2000 km de routes
2400 éléphants 1100 millions et plus de
12000 du flux
vous verrez
successivement bondir et glisser sur
votre écran les girafes les chiens
sauvages les zèbres une impressionnante
variété d'antilopes et buffles oreillers
et les crocos tic
ou véraison aussi dans les dernières
pages de ce livre d'image l'eau
rhinocéros noirs animal fabuleux myope
et colérique auquel ne sont pas aux
guerres que le buffle qui n'est pas plus
diplomate que lui
vous verrez aussi que les réserves
d'afrique du sud sont les seules régions
civilisé où le lion la priorité sur
l'automobile qu'ils viennent de gauche
ou de droite
jeudi les réserves d'afrique du sud car
il y en a plusieurs qui contiennent à
peu près tout le même assortiment de
bêtes sauvages
rendus à leur innocence primitive et qui
ne font plus peur aux enfants
une sorte de paradis terrestre
bien que l'on y rencontre des hommes
je
qui
m
non
ah ah
oh
et